joining me on stage is Jeremy from Sony
San Diego guns up buddy
so guns uppercut we were proud to
announce it on Monday at the press event
it's a free-to-play title it's available
or going to be available on PlayStation
4 PlayStation 3 and PS Vita and you'll
be able to play cross play cross save so
you know you pick up where you left off
your new ps4 running your Vita and it's
a really fun game we have it here on the
show and then so this is you know that
that what you described you know free to
play across place like it rattles off so
quickly but it's such an awesome part of
the so many sort of ecosystem is taking
these games I take advantage of I can
play it on here I played there on the go
and it's like persistent progress I
think that we live in a world of magic
and wonder Jeremy would you agree I
agree
people just but people just want things
to work right so we're trying to enable
that as much as possible all right well
let's take a look here at guns up we've
got someone we've got your buddy in the
back from Valhalla is it Valkyrie in her
tail kuri
yes all right great bunch of guys this
sub 10min team in Seattle Washington and
they've done a fantastic job with this
game alright so let's see if seeing it
in action my first impression of it was
this is like - tower defense matches
kind of facing off against each other is
that roughly accurate yeah so I think I
think it's a decent way of putting it so
basically in the game it's a
side-scrolling action strategy game so
it's very hectic there's a lot of
there's there's a lot of action you're
gonna be playing three main ways so you
can first attack another base which is
what we're showing here at e3 and what
we'll show will show in a minute you can
also create your own base and defend
against other people's attacks and the
third way of playing is a challenge mode
so these are custom tailored missions
that that you're gonna have with that
Valkyries created where we do things
like hey and can you beat this base in
under five minutes with just riflemen
it's something that organically we were
doing within the team we said you know
this is really fun we need to enable
this you need to like have these yeah
these one-off challenges because not
only are they sort of fun ways to
experiment with specific mechanics in
the game and sort of specific ways to
attack stuff but also it teaches you
about you know really how to get deep
into the strategy of the game so you
know I guess once you see the game in
action it's gonna come up here soon you
get a better sense for how much
it is action and how much is strategy
where would you kind of place it on that
spectrum well you know it's I think it's
I'm more of an action guy so I'll give
you an answer that someone from Valkyr
you may not give you money I I really
appreciate the action if if when we jump
right into it until level here you'll be
able to see that we want to make sure
that you constantly have something to do
at all times so when you're deploying
troops when you're using specials when
you're beginning pickups
there's always something fun for you do
you're not you don't ever just have to
sit back and kind of and just watch it
all play out like watching yes my minion
yes go boy it's like you got to be on it
right so back in the back here is
showing the game right now he's picking
a bunch of different units we got things
like rifleman that only cost 50
munitions or you can maybe pick someone
like a sniper he's 510 times much why
would I want to pick a sniper the sniper
is awesome that's why you want to pick
the sniper it takes guys out from long
range you can lined up enemies and take
out you know three four guys with one
shot
uh-huh it can be really effective in
addition to deploying guys you also have
the ability to do specials so maybe yeah
if you tried tear gas pack you can put
that over some enemies and that's going
to disorient them that gives you that
gives your your troop some time to move
forward in the frontline and take them
out why they're still coughing and
wheezing great take advantage up take
mountain so you've got your little
minions that sort of March more or less
relentlessly towards the enemy
fortifications here and you're basically
choosing all right you're choosing which
type of troops to spawn there at bottom
yep and then you've sort of got your
cooldown abilities or is it I just like
you spend however many usages you have
yeah you get those through the
battlefield know what while you're
playing and so you'll pick them up and
get their kind of one use you get one
use one you've got an inventory of them
alright great now he's about to do a
bombing run which is one of my favorites
widespread damage watch the bodies fly
come on boom so it's really satisfying
on you planet hey alright looks like
kind of a world war one world war two
aesthetic or like sort of placement in
on the on the timeline of militarize a
modern military warfare it's it's what
you want to make it you know we don't do
we don't we don't delve into the fiction
of story this is about gameplay this is
about player versus player competition
so I think you're gonna see some
elements that harken to some World War 2
era there's lost some things that you
know maybe they're a little bit more
features for more - it's it's really all
about the fun rather than trying to be
historically accurate at this one yeah
yeah yeah I think that's clear as we see
the the bodies fly and the tiny little
bullets pop up to give you the resources
that you did you need that decoy was
well timed if rocket barrage just went
over towards it so this is the this is
the mode that you were saying in which
pure assault
yes you're just heading towards the
enemy base and you can sort of see I
guess the UH tatata sort of the timeline
on the top shows you your relative
position and the paola far you have to
go yeah then what that's representing is
you know where your troops are in the in
the path the side-scrolling path from
where your troops started to where you
need to get to the end base and destroy
it
so here the blue one is you and the and
the red guys are showing you the enemy
troop locations as well as the
structures they destroy and of course
Beck is doing some serious damage to the
enemy right now so we're we're happy to
see him succeed paratroopers coming down
behind enemy lines yes well what happens
in all your paratroopers get killed and
then you run into so you get blasted up
by the enemy fail the mission guys start
again if you run out of resources you
got nothing left
yeah you're gonna have the surrender but
I have confidence that's not gonna
happen to back this time I think yeah
he's set up for success looking at the
interface it looks like on the Vita you
guys might be just going like straight
up touchscreen controls well I think
that's probably print one option that's
a pretty good that's a pretty good
observation and I think in the future
we're gonna be really excited about
showing what we're gonna do for each
individual platform I think there's some
really cool stuff things we can do on
beat us and really cool things we can do
on ps4 and we're some really cool things
on the ps3 want to make sure we take
advantage I mean we're this is a sony
published game we want to make sure that
we take advantage of each of the
hardware and show up showcase it to its
utmost capabilities all right well you
know that was one player attacking a
fortification of AI but what if that's
my friends base is that a possibility
here like a little head-to-head faceoff
action actually that's a great question
and what you actually saw there was
another human space
so we just we just created a couple
bases and we're having you attack those
so so on the on the off side of things
when you create your base you're gonna
have a permanent base lives in the cloud
that's where everything lives apparently
now oh yeah and you're gonna have
another wheel and that's where we are
right now I took the blue pill oh yeah
red blue red yeah I don't
okay anyway um where was I it's a blue
pill red pill you know these matrix how
do you always be around everybody that
so now you've got enemies attacking your
base yeah or or friends for that matter
and you're gonna be able to adjust that
upgrade the buildings and spend those
munitions to have the best possible base
and showcase like how strong you can be
so the base when you say base it's not
like just this sort of endgame area that
you're working towards it's this whole
linear it's the whole mission that your
table is your base absolutely and so
what if I you know what if my buddy
takes a shot at my base and he gets
repelled and I totally vanquishes troops
you know coming my way for it okay so we
got you covered
so if your buddy comes and attacks your
base you're gonna be able to replay see
what you did if you want to make some
tweaks and and and try to say hey you
want try it again you can do that if you
want to just shortcut revenge you can do
that to get him back so and that's an
interesting thing is the replay right
and you know like getting that data back
you can really like you expect people to
like it get hoping they're gonna get
involved and like get really like
after-action report on this stuff and
like oh no man I those flamethrowers
just shoot us off there on the whole mid
area we got to get some long-range
bombardment in there I mean everyone's
gonna have their own style I think for
me I got if someone attacks my base I
got maybe a chip on my shoulder I'm
coming after you you know and I think
there's some other people that think
that way so a pop-up notification like
you totally got beat by this guy are you
gonna tolerate that if someone attacked
your base would you sit there and take
it I don't know I wasn't it I would perk
me I think I would be very well hurt by
that
so cross-platform and cross save means
you know my buddy who's playing it on
this train will ride in on the morning
I'm sitting down to my ps4 tonight we
could have that
back at four absolutely yeah so you can
play on Vita I can play on ps4 you know
whatever whatever platform is gonna work
for you we want we're gonna make sure
that just is it seamless as possible all
right so this game is free-to-play yes
so this of course begs the question or
prompts the question I you know if I can
I put a little money into it can i soup
up my base with you know buying some
extra stuff to like try to get an edge
or employ some different strategies well
that that's a great question and you
know obviously we hope some people
decide to to help support the game and
spend a little bit of money yeah but if
you don't if you never spend a dime
you're gonna be able to play the
entirety of the game you're not going to
be at a competitive disadvantage we
think that's really important that we
don't we don't have a pay to win system
but if you do spend money you are gonna
be able to have shortcuts to its better
units faster than you would if you were
just grinding away you're gonna be able
to have more customization options so if
you want to make sure you know your
banner and your faction looks a
particular way you'll have more you'll
have more of those abilities if you help
support begin and how diverging you guys
going with this customization I mean can
I March my clown army into the you know
businessman central with the different
skins for my troops or are you sticking
pretty close to this sort of general
aesthetic well let me ask you can we use
that idea cuz I happen to really like
I'd be happy to sign that away to go for
a low low not zero price okay yes that
was for free just for coming on here and
showing off guns up and not making me
yell at every time I will get a clown
face in there if I have to I'll try I
trust good army thank you I trust the
you will let me do clown warfare so you
know this is sort of these games like
this always the tower defense games and
these kind of have a puzzle element to
them right you've got the relationship
of different you know guns to different
you know effectiveness it's not just a
linear sort of ramp up to from like you
know number the tommy gun to the bazooka
stuff has different strengths and
weaknesses has how's the balance bit for
you guys to sort of get it said and make
sure that stuff isn't too overpowered
our stuff works out all right that's a
great question so I think I think what I
think what's done is you know we try to
make the best guesses
at the beginning but in reality the only
way to really tell is to have people
play the game so one of the things we're
doing for e3 demo and we're really
excited about is after you play through
the game you have the ability to sign up
via either your email address or PSN ID
we're gonna take we're gonna take that
contact information and we're gonna be
able to send invites out to port for
people for alphas and betas and by that
you're gonna help make the game better
so those balancing issues you talk about
when we find out that hey rocket
launchers are too powerful
we'll have ability to to adjust that
based on what real users are doing and
that's been a theme I think here with a
lot of games sort of entering bait do
like betas that are actively you know
getting some data back in helping
balance more so than the beta that's
just like a demo or marketing beta yeah
is that is that the term yeah we I I'm
not a big fan of marketing betas we we
we this is gonna be a real baby this is
gonna be a beta about making sure that
the game is going to be better for the
for everyone because of real-world user
experiences alright so if people want to
sign up again that's just give which
where do they go to give you that
information and hopefully get on the
beta list I appreciate you asking so up
right now you can see what it looks like
in game this lineup screen you can also
go to www.deewr.gov.au/rjcp - details
we're gonna go